hello everyone and welcome to a very
interesting Blitz game I played on
leeches a few days ago I posted it on
Twitter as a as a gif or as a Jif we
already discussed that the creator of
the gift said that it's supposed to be
pronounced jiff but I'm still gonna go
with gif and the other guy said that I
should show it on the channel so here it
is and before we check out the game I
would just like to say that since a lot
of you are interested in the leeches
team battles I will create a poll where
you will be able to vote on the name of
our team I don't feel like picking a
name myself so feel free to suggest some
of the names for the team in this in in
the comments section below and then I'm
gonna choose some of them which are you
know some reasonable ones and put them
in a poll so we can vote on them so that
being said let's check out the game I
played against a user named rebel he was
rated at the time this game was played
some two thousand twenty two hundred and
eighty around that and I had the white
piece it's a three minute blitz game so
I hope you enjoy it with efore by me he
six dribble goes for the fringe defense
I go Knight to f3 and he goes for c5 so
transposing into the Sicilian defense
and since I don't have any information
on mr. drebber I'm using the photo of
the hoodie guy and in honor of the
hoodie guy I am of course we're wearing
a hoodie as well
we have d4 by me and a six and now as my
opponent did not attack the e4 pawn by
developing the night I play c4 which is
what I usually do when I can it's just
very very useful now we have Queen to c7
and now I go Knight to c3 and here there
is one game now in the database where b6
was played but here he goes for d6 and
it is already as a move 5 that we have a
completely new game so I continued
development prepared to the Castle
kingside he played Knight the d7 and I
went to Bishop to e3 still waiting with
castles
he played see captures on d4 I played
Knight capture Sunday for an Mountain I
to G to f6 just continuing development I
Castle kingside
and he he played b6 and now what I
should probably go is a f4 right away
but first I played
to see one I didn't really put much
thought into it it's a three minute
Blitz game and I thought it's just gonna
be very useful to have this rook here
and the same file as the black queen so
he played a bishop to be seven he put
pressure on my e4 pawn here and I didn't
defend it I should have played f3 but I
went f4 all the way his King is still in
the center of the board he if he castles
Queen side I thought that's not gonna be
a problem and he's still two moves away
from castling kingside so I gave up the
e4 pawn he captured it with the night
and I continued with f5 still he has to
do something so he played Knight
captures in c3 he's up upon so why not
trade now and even further I played rook
captures on c3 and now II five and just
getting rid of the tension in the center
and now attacking my knight and if you
put this position to to an engine the
engine will give you an ID be three
Knights e2 Knight f3 but I of course
went for Knight the e6 and this is where
our game begins so you definitely
captured an idea if you don't take it
it's just you're allowing a monster
night on e6 and move 14 so he of course
captured and it is the strongest move
and I played F captures on e6 right away
you could go for Bishop to h5 check and
then he might run into some problems see
if he blocks with g6 you open a bf file
but instead I played F chapters on e6
attack tears night and after Knight to
f6 here
I played rook captures on f6 you you
could also go for blush of h5 check with
some ideas like night cap pursue rook f7
attack the Queen but you will not have
time to recapture the knight here
because Queen to c6 comes comes with a
mate threat so it's not not very useful
so instead I just played rook captures
on f6 I removed the defender of the h5
Square and also if he captures the rook
he will no longer have g6 at his
disposal so he played G captures on f6
and I played Bishop to h5 with check and
here is where he really could have
played a better move well the only the
only playable moves are basically King
d8 and King to e7 he played King to d8
here came that e 7 is what what you
should have played but again it's a
three minute blitz game it's hard really
side were to put your king but here he
would be perfectly fine here there
basically is nothing white can do here
but I mean there's nothing white can do
here if this was a normal game in a
blitz game anything can happen you can
play Bishop f7 play something like B for
c5 and bust open the position and black
still has a king in the center of the
board but he played King to d8 and he
allowed me this very tricky c5 move and
now he has he has some problems he
cannot capture as this pawn is pinned he
could capture with the beep on and this
is what I thought he would do because if
pawn captures I can just play rook
captures on c5 and even though I'm down
the rook I'm not all that much worse I
have a pawn on e6 I have a broken c5 the
Queen on d1 the bishop slicing over here
after the rook moves I could maybe I get
the Bishop over to b6 create some
threads there and here he would have to
find Bishop to c6 it's a silly-looking
move and they're not looking move to
play but after Bishop to c6 he would be
very much ok it's it's very much unclear
how you would continue this game you
have to go back with the rook and then
well try it look for a chance as
elsewhere but it's not like you were
clearly down the rook but instead after
this a c5 move I made he played rook to
g8
he created a threat of his own just a
rook captures on g2 as a bishop covers
death square as well but this gives me
all the time in the world I need to get
seek address on d6 in I didn't think I
saw a rookie actress Angie too but I
just didn't see if there was any other
way he could create some threats so he
played root cap person g2 with check if
you try Queen cap for some d6 that's not
gonna work you can just either go rook
to d3 or even better Bishop captures
with check now you don't really have a
good square for King you have to play
King e7 and now Bishop c5 just wins the
Queen this way so instead he played rook
actress Angie - with chick I have to go
to f1 if I go king h1 then you just move
the rook and it's well not there
obviously but Ruby g4 so you block the
bishops retreat and this one our result
in mate it's Chuck and the ones you give
up the rook and the Queen the this is
checkmate
so of course I went to the f1 King f1
and now I didn't I didn't
see any way for him to continue the
attack and he didn't find any useful
move either I mean you could play a
bunch of characters here but you're just
giving up a queen if you go Queen
captures on d6 you run into the into the
same idea just captures here with Czech
Queen the King g7 and again Bishop c5
will win the Queen
so after this scheme to f1 move he
played Queen captures on c3 he decided
to give up the Queen to create some room
for for his king but I just continued
with the attack I played Bishop captures
and b6 with Chuck he played King to c8
only move if you don't want to part with
your Queen this way I played the d7
width track he played King to b8 and
here I just played B captors on c3 it is
the most correct move to play you just
bringing out the Queen also wins but I
decided to capture the Queen as I saw
there's nothing else for him to do and
here he just played rook character Sun
h2 and now III I had to figure out a way
to do it and I didn't want to waste too
much time
so I played Queen to d6 with Czech it's
it's very interesting but it's actually
a mating too because after d8 Queen he
has to block with the bishop and now
Queen to c7 is mate but I didn't find
this mate I thought that after they live
after bringing you a queen enter game I
have to do this check Queen d6 check so
instead I first gave up the Queen with
check so after he captured it now I
brought a queen into the game and after
he blocked it now I just captured with
Czech he played King to here and I just
played the Queen to c7 mate so instead
of a mating - I found mate in three but
still I was I was very very happy with
my game and a lot of you enjoyed it on
Twitter so I thought you might also
enjoy it here as it's not well it's it's
very interesting it's it's it has
mistakes make no mistake but still in a
three minute boots game you have to you
have to try and exploit that and it's
always easier to attack them to defend
and this time I was able to I was able
to pull it off so if you want to go
through the game yourself yourselves
that will put the PGN and also the link
to delicious game in the description
below if you want to check that out and
yeah it's not very often that I will
show some
this blitz game I played only chess but
like I said you you said maybe I should
do it and so so here it is a very nice
idea and it's not even if black defended
properly after after that c5 move it
wasn't all that easy to defend even
being down the rook white still has a
whole board at his disposal and I just
well I just very much enjoyed playing
this game that's that's basically what
I'm saying so that's the game I'd hope
you enjoyed it don't forget the name
some team names in the comment section
below
so we can use it for early chess team
battles and then we're going to create a
poll to vote a vote on the names I would
like to thank Volker Legrand for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the Vita
Grand Prix we are waiting to see if
Maxine will qualify into the candidates
tournament checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and as always whatever or
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day